لكان خيرا لهم
هذه الكلمه لكان خيرا لهم
قد يفهم من هذا
اسم التفضيل
يعني لكان خيرا لهم من ان يصدقوا الله
وهذا
ليس من باب التفضيل احيانا ياتي
اسم التفضيل ولا يراد به التفضيل وانما
يراد به
ذكر الفضل باعلى مراتبه
والا لكان المعنى فلو صدقوا الله لكان
خيرا لهم من ان يكذبوا الله
او من ان يكذبوا مع الله هذا لا يستقيم
لانه كيف الانسان يقول مثلا الجنه خير من
النار
الصدق خير من من
الجنه خير من النار او الصدق خير من الكذب
يفهم من هذا المشاركه وليس هذا هو المراد
بل المراد لكان ذلك هو الخير لهم لاصابوا
الخير والخير
‏in Arabic and is not me that is better
than that which is good.
‏What's meant is that is best
right? So for instance if we were to say
paradise is better than hell
we to make that statement this statement
is slightly flawed.
Why?
Because the listener could understand
that the hell fire has some good in it.
But paradise is ultimately better.
‏a person said truthfulness is better
than falsehood
this is well a flat
if we are to understand it as it is
present this could me that false has
some good to it but tru is better this
is what we call
in
which is two things
‏other
those words are used in Arabic but it
doesn't mean that those that that what
that word is being used with that it is
necessarily an issue of good and better
bad and worse.
‏andيره
رضي الله عنه ابوهريره
صحيح البخاري
صلى الله عليه وسلم
يا رسول الله
من اسعد الناس بشفاعتك يوم القيامه
من اسعد الناس
يفهم من ظاهر الكلام ثم سعيد
بشفاعه الرسول وثم
اسعد
بشفاعه الرسول وليس هذا هو المراد من
السؤال لان جواب النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
من قال لا اله الا الله صادقا من قلبه
طيب واللي ما يقول لا اله الا الله صادقا
من قلبه ماذا نسميه؟ هذا هو الكافر اذا
معناه ان الكافر له سعاده بشفاعه الرسول
لا بل المقصود
من السعيد بشفاعتك يعني من ينال شفاعتك
فقال من قال لا اله الا الله كل من قال لا
اله الا الله واما من لم يقل لا اله الا
الله خالصا من قلبه فليس له حظ من الشفاعه
هذا هو معنى الحديثيره
من صحيح البخاري
صلى الله عليه وسلم
‏will
be the
recipient of your intercession on the
day of judgment this is how it is most
often translated
and this is a mistaken translation who
is the recipient of your
of your
answer is whoever
لا اله الا الله
شفاعه
interes
‏and translation
will happent
فهنا التفضيل على غير بابه هكذا العلماء
يقولون واسم التفضيل على غير بابه
فقوله تعالى لكان خيرا لهم
اي
من باب انهم ان لم يفعلوا ذلك لكان شرا
لهم وهذا اسم تفضيل على غير بابه الله
سبحانه وتعالى
21 سوره محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
‏would
be with
not understand
that if person is not
will
be
not as
الله سبحانه وىق
[Silence]
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى ان يجعلنا
جميعا من الصادقين وان يجعلنا من الصادقين
ومع الصادقين وفي الصادقين
وان
ينجينا
من الكذب والكذابين والكاذبين يوم القيامه
وفي الدنيا والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على
نبينا محمد